good morning
I uh before we get going I'd like to
mention that we will be having hearings
two days a week
uh probably
for for as long as we can manage we the
house will be meeting in session pretty
much every Thursday in February except
for the last week which is vacation week
and
next week we will be meeting on
Wednesday
and Thursday unless the speaker
schedules a session in which case it
will be on Friday sorry about that but
that's we've got a dozen early bills we
have to hear
so I'd rather
face up to it and schedule the the
hearings as soon as possible
all right
and I'd like to welcome representative
Dolan who has
been unable to attend our previous
meetings
and
open the hearing for House Bill 355 and
call Representative Gallagher and if you
would put in a pink card representative
Galler or at after the end of your
testimony please
foreign
Gallagher representing Merrimack County
District 20. which is conquered Ward 6.
um so I am here
to introduce
house bill
355 establishing a committee to study
the sharing of data between state and
federal public housing agencies
um
so
yeah if
if you tend to
get in political debates often which
most of us as legislators I'm assuming
do one
phrase
that you might hear
people say as well if you don't like it
then leave
so
the thing about that though is
that
it's actually
rather hard to do that for
certain people for for example those
living in public housing
so um
if
if someone in public housing
wants to move
they can't just
transfer
their data
and and move they have to restart the
application process
from the beginning again
and
um
so
I actually put in
a research request
about this to OLS
and um
they they did get back to me
um I think it was
um
yeah I got some responses from I think
it was Jack reuterman who
um
mentioned about some of the ways that
data sharing already happens
um
between state and federal
housing agencies
um
but
um so yeah um
yeah they they weren't able to turn
those
research results into
um an actual
Bill unfortunately so instead um it's
become a
uh study committee so we can find out
um
more
details about how to turn it into
actual legislation
um
so yeah I think this would be
helpful for housing to help streamline
the application process
um
so that way
people can get
in more easily and uh
can do foot folding to live where
they want to and feel most comfortable
um
and yeah because Concord for example the
Concord public housing the Concord
Housing Authority closed applications
just because there were
it was so far behind on them so um
I I think having some data portability
to uh
to
help reduce
the
amount of
retyping the same information every time
would help things go more smoothly so
that's why I've proposed this bill and
I'll take any questions
thank you very much
are there questions from the committee
representative Lucas
thank you
um so are you worried about data sharing
between different housing authorities
within the state of New Hampshire mainly
or is it Interstate what what do you get
well
um both I I would like I I would like
the study committee to look at both of
those
can you follow up follow-up so so there
is actually a problem between housing
authorities within the state they each
have their own system and everything is
that correct
um
yeah I I would like the site you create
who look at that as well
all right thank you
thank you chairman
do you see any potential conflict in the
sharing the information with the feds uh
and our state privacy Amendment
um
well as this is Sie committee um I I
think that is something that it could
figure out is if any such conflict
exists um I mean I I was thinking if we
do set up something like this that you
know the people
people could choose to take part in it
or not
um
you know just add another check box
and
um
but again that would be something for
the study committee too
figure out
representative
good morning thank you chair my question
is what kind of data gets
moved from the state level to the
federal level
well there's all sorts of
well so
um
whether
you're receiving funding through HUD or
not so
um
like
the Concord Housing Authority for
example
it's a local agency but it's also HUD
housing and then HUD is a federal agency
and you have to do all these sorts of
redetermination paperworks to see if you
qualify
for it or not
um
so and yeah that goes to both the
concrete Housing Authority
and
to the federal government uh for
determining uh
for HUD purposes so
um
this would help clarify who gets what
from that process
thank you follow on follow-up follow-up
you stated that this is a local plus
estate plus a federal who would share
the tax burden of sharing data
especially if software systems are
separate
um
well yes asset study committee um that
would be within the domain of things for
the study committee to
figure out
um yeah you know that's why
it is just a study committee is because
we we don't have all those answers yet
thank you uh representative you have a
question yes thank you
um representative Gallagher
um
what kind of
organizations you see
would testify before this committee
and
could they have been part of The
Originals I guess this is a question for
anyone at this table could a member of
one of those committees have been a
member of this committee
um so yeah um
well
so I was thinking local housing
authorities
um
and
yeah so it's um
so yeah there's there's two separate
parts so there's members of the
committee and then who comes and
testifies before it so um yeah the
members are legislators
and then uh it says appointed by the
speaker so
um yeah he could pick them from this
committee and then for people who would
come and testify before it
um I would be thinking people from how
housing agencies like Concord housing
for instance
um and um
then um
yeah when I asked OLS to do a research
request
about this
um
the people that they
reached out to
um
so yeah I I
um I forget the exact exact Department
that uh Jack ritterman is the head of
but um I can find that in my email and
forward that to all of you
um
and I it might um
then like the New Hampshire Housing
Finance Authority
um
and
um like the one that Ben Frost is with
um and and also New Hampshire does have
its own HUD office
um
in
uh Manchester I emailed them about this
but they seem to think I actually want
to get in touch with the New Hampshire
Housing Finance Authority so there's a
little bit of confusion
there as well about whose responsibility
which pieces of data are
um
so
yeah I would think that
they would come before the committee as
witnesses as well
are there when you were preparing your
testimony did you ask support from any
of these other organizations to come and
testify before the committee
um not to not to come and testify here
specifically mostly I just asked them
for information about
how the current system works
um
and
yeah when
it turned out that
of the current information that I got
from them wasn't enough then that's
um
that's when it turned into they study
committee to the TF play
maybe other members would have better
questions for them on how to
turn this
into actual legislation
thank you representative Brian
thank you madam chair representative
crota uh asked and had my question
answered thank you oh how convenient
representative Dolan yes thank you madam
Madam chair uh representative Gallagher
uh the way this uh
Poe's law is written up uh are you aware
of and are you okay with the fact that
this uh will sunset this coming November
and finish up with a final report
um
that seems like a reasonable time frame
to me
um were you thinking were you thinking
that's too short or too long no I just
want to make sure that as a sponsor of
the legislation that you're you weren't
caught by surprise by that uh
yeah I I think November 1st is a
reasonable due date but um if I
um
yeah if this committee would like to
change it I would be open to that
thank you thank you madam chair
thank you madam chair
representative Gallagher did you seek
any co-sponsors on this bill or did you
ask co-sponsors and not not have any
thank you
um
yeah I
I don't think this was one of the bills
that I saw co-sponsors on uh yeah I'm on
a lot of bills this term so it's it's
hard to keep some of them straight
sometimes but
all right other questions the
representative thank you very much
representative Gallagher Jack rutterman
good maybe you can answer some of the
questions that I couldn't
thank you madam chair good morning
committee members my name is Jack
Ruderman I am with
sorry I'm with New Hampshire housing
um also known as New Hampshire Housing
Finance Authority I serve as the manager
for public affairs we were contacted by
representative Gallagher and uh or
indirectly through
um
office of legislative services at some
point
and we don't really um
we don't really have a position on the
bill but two things that I wanted to
make cleared in the committee are
number one we're not a state agency and
in the conventional sense of the word
um were a state Authority so we're we're
quasi governmental
um and secondly
we're not a public housing authority
um
so we um we help promote support and
finance uh affordable housing
development around the state
um but we don't actually serve as the
state's public housing authority or
um you know we're not in the same
league with let's say the Portsmouth
Housing Authority or the Concord Housing
Authority so I just wanted to to make
those clarifications but um you know I'm
certainly sympathetic to representative
Gallagher's concerns uh and I'm you know
we are not opposing
um this bill and
um to the extent that we can be helpful
we'd be happy to to keep
um stay involved um should the committee
wish to establish the study Commission
thank you
are there questions right yes
representative Gould
hi can you tell me how many staff you
have in your department
uh we have roughly 140 people
and do you
um follow-up follow-up
do you thank you madam chair do you
um
accumulate data
on housing issues homelessness
yes we do and we do manage the state's
housing Choice voucher program or
Section 8 program as it's commonly known
so we have we have data on the folks who
are participants in that program
but we don't have data you know if
someone said
um could you please take a look at
resident X's data because we want to
share that data with another Authority
we we wouldn't have the information
okay thank you representative O'Brien
thank you uh Madam Sharon thank you Mr
rutterman for taking my question uh I
understand your uh New Hampshire housing
has no position on it and I don't mean
to put you on the spot
but the thing is in looking at this did
was it ever a discussion of a
cost-benefit analysis do you see a need
for this you know or is it you know I
just don't want to create another level
of bureaucracy if not needed so if you
can I know you put in a position of
Noah pen you know no position but could
you explain further
thank you for the question
representative
um
because we're not a housing authority
and I'm really not I'm not trying to
dodge your question but because we're
not a housing authority and we don't
have that data
um I don't know what it would take
um to actually make that data
transportable but
um if there is to be a study uh
committee then I think the folks who
manage you know the the six or seven
Regional public housing authorities in
the state could could speak to that and
I'm sorry but I just don't know whether
that's a simple thing to do with an
application to upload it from one agency
to another or whether it would be
complicated
thank you other questions
oh yes representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair good morning sir
uh so uh in the healthcare field uh
there's I am the chairman of the
Stratford County delegation okay so we
we had a situation several years ago
where uh we also tried to streamline
things because one of the things that we
discovered and I'm sure you deal with
something similar to yourself somebody
comes in they have to go through all the
paperwork name address social security
number in some cases and so forth over
and over and over again this that it's
it's the same data for the individual
everywhere he or she goes right so the
idea that you have to repeat it over and
over again and that the agency also has
to uh have the the same stuff that some
other agency doing the same kind of work
would have would it not be a a
facilitation of
both sides to have data sharing
capability and and I'm sure to some
degree they're already doing it uh but
but that's the purpose of the study
committee as I see it is to is to save
this you go out of the you go in the
door of this institution you come back
out you go in another Silo come back out
you go on another Silo over and over
again for one thing and one of the
things we discovered was that it's very
psychologically innervating to have to
do that and it's also a waste of time I
believe so you're not taking a position
but you do see that this would the study
of the data sharing could be useful
absolutely thank you very much other
questions
all right seeing none thank you Mr
Ruderman thank you
bill 355.
all right seeing none I will close the
hearing
if you want to open up the executive
session I'll be I'd like to present the
committee with a motion
all right without objection we'll go
into executive session
representative broader thank you I'm
going to recommend itl for house bill
355.
is there a second
representative true was first that I saw
at least okay do you want to speak to
your motion
I would thank you
um
Jeremy McGuire
although I see
that this is an interesting
topic and needed information
because we have an affordable housing
commission going on now
um and it seems to me that
there are so many independent
organizations that would be involved
with this and it would be a voluntary
program ultimately
I I think that the study commission is
premature and I also don't think that
the November deadline would be adequate
considering the effort that would it
would take to get this done that's my
concern with the bill and um I don't
necessarily like to
um present motions prematurely but I
think that in this case
it's appropriate
thank you representative true do you
wish to speak to your second no all
right
is there any other
comments questions
okay
seeing none the motion is in expedient
to legislate on House Bill 355 by
representative groda and the clerk and
call the rule
representative chairman I'm sorry Simon
yes representative Lucas yes
representative Bailey
yes representative Santo nastasso yes
representative true
yes representative Dolan yes
representative a bear yes representative
Gerhard yes the clerk votes yes
representative vergoda yes
representative Schmidt
but not here
I'm just double checking I thought it
was okay uh
quite okay I get confused with
representative Smith in the Stratford
County all the time
um I vote Yes
representative goalie yes representative
schuett yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould
yes and the chair
the vote to 18-0
uh right between the motion to 18 to
zero the motion passes
is there any objection to consent
all right seeing none thank you
representative groder I'd like a
committee report
uh
by Tuesday at the very latest and the
sooner the better
I think I owe you several and I'll be
sure to get them done
okay
um
and we have
one minute before 399.
yes sir
it says
House Bill what
is a schedule
foreign
like an error somewhere let me look look
at my master list and I will confirm
um
okay
everything
foreign
it's uh 10 30 and I'm opening the
hearing on House Bill 391.
and
representative Murphy
if you could give us a pink card we'd
when you're through testifying I'd
appreciate it
what
she did oh you have to first I asked you
to to submit a pink card when you're
through with your testimony and be sure
and turn your microphone on and speak
into it
um it's not on yet
the red lights would see oh hear me
thank you good morning Madam chair and
his team members of the committee
um I'm Nancy Murphy representing
Hillsboro 12 the town of Merrimack I
come before you this morning to
introduce HB 391 which has been filed to
amend current RSA 126a colon 76. I have
some handouts with that statute included
which if I could please hand up thank
you
okay the Genesis of the RSA
um was rep Mark Pearson's 2018 HB 1356
when he was chair of the commission on
environmentally triggered chronic
illness along with a few other
requirements this statute necessitates
that des and DHHS establish and
Implement a data sharing protocol
regarding certain health and
environmental information collected by
the agencies
the Des and DHHS have an updated
memorandum of agreement on cooperation
regarding data sharing between the
agencies
a joint standard operating procedure on
how data layers can be shared between
the two departments must be in place to
enable the agencies to collaboratively
identify linkage linkages between
environmental contaminants and health
outcomes
and a semi-annual report shall be
submitted regarding the data sharing
practices required under the statute to
the Speaker of the House the Senate
President the State library and the
commission to study environmentally
triggered chronic illness I think it's
important to note here that when we
reference the sharing of Health Data the
statute specifically states that only
non-protected health information or
aggregate aggregated data shall be made
available where it is pertinent to the
matter being addressed there's no
requirement to disclose confidential or
personally identifiable information
otherwise protected by state or federal
law HIPAA compliance is prioritized by
the agency and personal privacy remains
protected
HB 391 is meant to First clarify the
ongoing nature of the memorandum of
agreement between Des and DHHS regarding
data sharing practices
to ensure that an agreement remains in
effect without lapse HB 391 aims to
ensure that a memorandum of agreement
between DHHS and Des remain current and
in place as is required by Statute
it's my understanding that due to an
oversight the memorandum of agreement
between the agencies actually lapsed in
June of 2022 possibly due to some
administrative procedural terminology
changes relative to moas and mous that
may have delayed things since this LSR
has been filed I've been informed that
it is an effort is actively underway to
update that agreement
I know that some of the agency
Representatives I've been working with
are here who can speak a bit more about
the one
one of the proposed agency mou versus Mo
uh a terminology changes that have come
up in discussion in reference to the
current Statute in hb39 and I'll leave
that to them
HB 391 is also meant to reduce the
semi-annual reporting requirements to an
annual one this came as a request of
DHHS
it will also delete reference to and
remove the requirement for reporting on
the arsenic in drinking water two-way
pilot project as that pilot project is
no longer in existence
and finally it will add the commission
on the environmental and public health
impacts of per and polyfluoroacal
substances to the entities that will
receive a copy of the annual report
referencing the environmental and Health
Data sharing practices required under
the state RSA
given the environmental and public
health challenges New Hampshire
currently faces there's no question that
ongoing collaboration and data sharing
between the agencies is both necessary
and appropriate to properly address the
relationship between the environment and
Public Health
though concerns about Arsenic and other
contaminants may have precipitated HB
1356 in 2018
concerns about environmental
contaminants like pfas and our air soil
and drinking water
lead in our homes and the pipes and
Faucets in our schools Etc and the
impact of all of these things on public
health deserve our attention today
data collection and sharing provides our
state agency's key environmental and
health information that drives decision
making and has the ability to positively
impact the health and well-being of New
Hampshire citizens I'm happy to take
questions and know that the a Regency
Representatives I've been working with
are here to respond as well thank you
for your time and attention and I ask
that you please consider voting OTP on
HB 391
um after based on some of the
discussions with DHHS and Des if the
committee determines
um after agency input that amendment to
certain language might be best and
wishes for me to provide an amendment
I'd be happy to to request one thank you
thank you
um representative Schmidt you have a
question
I do thank you madam chair good morning
representative Murphy
I notice there's no fiscal note uh I'm a
little bit surprised uh because it seems
like there would be some cost uh for
something which is going to go forward
and not lapse
so is this something that you are
concerned about that there is no fiscal
note no no there's there's
um in statute right now there's a
requirement that that agreement be in
place it just this bill would just
require that it not laps so it's not
it's it's not there's no fiscal note
because it's it's actually already in
place it just needs to be updated it's a
matter and and I I know
um maybe Des will speak to the where
they're at in that process already
if you've considered that I'm okay with
it yes thank you thank you any other
questions representative O'Brien thank
you madam chair and thank you
representative for taking my question uh
could you just briefly go over I'm from
Nashua and uh quite familiar with what's
going on with Merrimack as you know we
have the public national public water
supply is the pentacha cooperation and
we are watching that could you just
briefly explain to this committee why is
this particular bill is so important as
far as the reporting and everything else
that will come out of it because of uh
Saint-Germain and everything
sure thank you for your question
um this this uh data sharing agreement
was put in place
right back in 2018 and I know at that
time pfest was already a concern um it
had been discovered uh in the Merrimack
area in 2016 in our public drinking
water
um and it remains problematic for for
our community as well as the concern
about the health impacts related to our
long-term and ongoing exposure
um the um
the the agencies because of the overlap
in the concerns whether they're the
impact of environmental contaminants on
health
um must work together and collaborate
and they do and they do a great job of
that and we want to ensure that that
continues
um the the specifics and actually in
those reports you'll see some examples
of
um updates from the agencies relative to
the issues that are being addressed
collaboratively by the agencies and the
biomonitoring program is mentioned in
there and I I know you know there are
people in in the Merrimack area that
have been included as subjects and that
uh in that in that project as well as a
number of others the Merrimack cancer
investigation is included as well
um and I'm I know recently there was
another actually last December on
December 10th there was an Announcement
by DHHS that the town of Merrimack
has a a increased risk of kidney and
renal pelvis cancers
that at this point we certainly can't
aren't saying is related to
um to uh it's caused by p-fest but
kidney and renal pelvis cancers are
known to be associated with pfas and
where
um you know we're pretty impacted by by
the emissions from from Saint Cobain so
uh pfest is one of those issues and you
know there are almost 30 000 people in
Merrimack and um
it's certainly a a uh a health concern
around that particular environmental uh
contaminant and that was actually one of
the reasons for the request that the
report go to the new ham the pfest
commission the HB 737pfest commission as
well because much of our work the SB 85
commission environmentally triggered
chronic illness and HB 737 pfest
commission we do a lot of parallel work
and there's a lot of overlap so
I hope that answers your question thank
you it did for every answer thank you
very much Madam chair I yield
other questions
seeing none oh excuse me representative
Dolan
thank you madam chair representative
one thing that I'm glad you're looking
into the the pfas issue that's the uh
the more the publicity the publicity
around that issue is uh heightened but
my question is it looks like you've
struck
the language around arsenic uh and so
forth and and we know that
pfas is
caused by pollutants where arsenic is
mostly naturally occurring
but it's also
probably the biggest health hazard in
New Hampshire
We Know It causes learning disabilities
and so forth and young children are you
concerned at all that that the way the
language is coming out of this uh this
bill that we should be only caring about
pfas and no longer Cure by arsenic thank
you for your question no not at all
because arsenic LED we have a number of
environmental triggers of chronic
illness that we should be concerned
about the only reason to strike that
language is because that language in
statute currently is specific to a pilot
project regarding Arsenic and drinking
water that is no longer in effect so the
pilot project itself no longer exists so
that's the rationale for removing that
language although
um I'm sure the the agencies will tell
you that arsenic is certainly one of
those things that they continue as to to
Monitor and report on arsenic lead and
all those other issues so it's not
um it's not that the um that this bill
would remove study of that or
collaboration around those concerns it's
just specific to a a project that is no
longer in existence
thank you other questions
seeing none thank you very much
representative thank you
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill 391
yes
please sit down and introduce yourselves
and uh
fill out a pink card when you're
complete
good morning my name is Abby Rogers I'm
the legislative liaison for the division
of Public Health Services at DHHS uh
representative McGuire we did send a
card around I don't know maybe it may be
coming your way but we'll be happy to
fill one out again
foreign
good morning my name is Michelle Roberge
and I'm the uh
DHHS division of Public Health Services
bureau chief
thank you we are here to provide some
information related to HB 391 we had
spoken with the sponsor representative
Murphy on this bill I just wanted to be
clear that we are not taking a position
but I'd be happy to answer some
questions and provide information on the
language
thank you madam chair
representative Murphy's bill
um moves from six months to a year
is that a satisfactory or is it timely
would six months get you a better jump
on the issue
the department doesn't have any concerns
with the changing of the reporting
requirement in terms of frequency or
also including the additional commission
the Merrimack pfas commission as well so
we're amenable to those changes
thank you
um the sponsor of the bill
representative Murphy
mentioned the fact that there had been a
lapse in this
study and this communication can you
explain why that happened and how this
bill Rectify that right so
um with regard to the labs it was just
an inadvertent lapse of of not renewing
the Moa I do want to just inform the
committee that the department does not
think that it's necessary actually to be
codified in a statute to have this MLA
codified in statute because it is our
common practice to do this work anyways
so our data our aggregated data is on
our website and so anyone has access
including the Department of
Environmental Services and the
Departments are committed to working
together to provide any technical
assistance or guidance around the
agency's public data so
although there was a lapse it did not
the absence of an existing MOA did not
prevent the Department's either
Department from working together and
sharing the aggregated data so I just
want to and just inform the committee
that although the the mou did lapse
inadvertently it was it did not impact
the ability for the agencies to work
together or share data follow-up
follow-up so although there was a lapse
in the agreement the the actual data was
still collected and shared right it's
publicly publicly available data both
agencies have publicly available data
and I will also just inform for any data
that is has protected health information
and this is particular to the Department
of Health and Human Services any data
that we share that is protected health
information that would need a specific
data sharing agreement because we are a
HIPAA compliant agency and so this
overarching mou or MOA would not allow
us to share that the the protected
health information we would need an
additional specific data sharing
agreement to share that data and it's
all about making sure that we're
protecting privacy because it does have
protected health and it would have
protected health information and and
those data sharing Agreements are
established by project and by by data
set needed so we would want to make sure
we understood you know why an agency or
an entity would be requesting that data
what they would be doing with it how
they would be using that data so that's
all part of the requirements as being a
HIPAA compliant agency that we need to
ensure that that data is protected
before sharing it but this data shared
with with between HHS and Des does not
contain individual health data correct
that's correct so the data that the mou
or MOA is referring to is aggregated
data that is not protected health
information and is publicly available
you could go on the DHHS data portal
currently and see the data that's
available in aggregated form thank you
other questions representative
thank you so given that
um
I mean is there any point to anything in
126-a76 other than maybe D Roman 3
requiring a report
I mean do you need this to do what
you're doing
no we currently don't the mo the Moa or
mou does not you know as I said doesn't
prevent us from doing what we're
currently doing in practice
the language and the latter part of the
bill under three the department is
amenable to modifying the report
frequency to being one year and then
sharing that report with the other
Commission
yeah I guess my point is
um
you know if we eliminated the whole
thing other than maybe uh Roman 3
does that change anything
thank you for the question
um as the the requirement for the data
sharing um and 126a 76 came from uh work
that the commission on environment
environmentally triggered chronic
illness from SB 80 I guess it was his SP
85 currently as we know at the
commission um it was put in effect back
in 2018 we don't have a problem with
having that in statute the issue I think
that we wanted to bring to the
community's attention is that in
representative Murphy's language we
understand that because there was a
lapse in the agreement you know the
typically the and we have shared that
the information continuously was shared
even though the document lapsed that our
understanding in working at the new mou
um with the Department of Environmental
Services which should be completed
shortly is that mousse cannot be
designated in a non-lap status so they
do have to have an end date and they do
have to be reviewed so the only issue
that I wanted to bring up you know for
the Committees the Do Not lapse language
doesn't go with what our legal advice
had been on from our legal department
related to mou's needing to have an end
date quick quick follow-up yeah I'm
looking for a yes or no answer and that
is
if we got rid of this 126 a76
would you have to change anything you do
other maybe the reporting things do you
need any Authority in here to do what
you're doing that's kind of yes or no
I think the answer would be no to that I
can just say that the SB 85 commission
looks forward to our report we would
continue to do it and it's just keeping
you know the reporting requirement in
place it just you know gives the gives
the agencies uh you know a reference
point to when the reporting is due due
to the previous statute okay thank you
welcome all right thank you
representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair good morning Abby
good morning nice to see you and
Michelle as well of course I just don't
know quite as well so uh one of the
things that those of us who've been on
the committee for a while are well aware
of is that this situation that
representative Murphy is especially
concerned about naming Merrimack is not
limited of course to Merrimack it's uh
the the the chemicals of p5s and so
forth that have spread Beyond Merrimack
and they are uh in in other surrounding
communities as well I believe uh Madbury
medals in Dover also has an occurrence
of uh pfas and other related chemicals
so uh the remarks you made with regard
to the ongoing
monitoring and study and so forth that
applies Statewide if you will in terms
of the monitoring you do it's not just
limited to this subject of
Representative Murphy's bill
if I may ask a clarifying question when
you refer to monitoring can you can you
expand on that a little bit are you
talking about monitoring of water
quality or what is the okay well I'm
especially concerned about pfas we as
you probably recall there was a a rule
that came to the jail car about
I think about two years ago the pandemic
kind of distorts my recollection of time
but a couple of years ago representative
McGuire probably remembers as well uh a
rule that was going to require
communities to test their water
to see if they had uh pifas in their
water
that's a relatively inexpensive
operation to do the test uh if there's
pedophiles are found or any of the
analogous chemicals then then
remediation would be a a totally
different issue in terms of cost but uh
so that that was a requirement and the
rule was adopted went into effect
and so my question is whether the this
that that was a form of monitoring but
whether the department is also
continuing to
use use some other word than monitoring
can continuing to stay in touch with the
development because the contamination
process is ongoing hasn't been stopped
and it's just remediation it continues
so what is the department doing if if
this if this study is not if this bill
is not adopted you said that wouldn't
have any impact on what you're doing and
I'm asking whether you are in touch with
the situation wherever pfas has been
found in the state of New Hampshire yes
I'll defer to the Department of
Environmental Services for specific uh
you know responses relative to the
actual rules and or monitoring of the
pfas because that really falls under
their purview but I will say that the
Departments the two departments Health
and Human Services and Des works very
closely on all environmental health
issues including pfas issues and
certainly the department uh Health and
Human Services would follow any
recommendations on uh like private well
water testing uh you know
recommendations on uh people to to to
test their well water to make sure that
they are aware of what may be in their
well water we we would follow those
recommendations and encourage any any
person on private well water to do well
water testing so hopefully that answers
your question I think some of your
question might be more relevant for Des
yeah that is helpful but I will pursue
that thank you thank you thank you
representative brother
so for those of us where this is not as
obvious what data are you sharing like
what data does the Des share and what
data do you share where is what is the
data that you're sharing so the day so
the Department of Health and Human
Services has what we call our our DHHS
data portal and you can go on to that
well it's it's publicly available on our
website it includes data uh there's data
on childhood lead poisoning there's well
water there's a well water dashboard up
there there's climb some climate and
health there's
I I apologize I don't know all the data
off the top of my head but I certainly
it is publicly available on our on our
website and it's uh the repository for
it is known as DHHS data portal
follow up I guess because I'm sorry
follow up follow up because we're
talking about pfas what specific data
are you sharing about pfat I mean this
is what this is no no they're giving the
data they have on public health
chronic illness cancer I'm sure
to the commission that is working on
pfax and the commission on
um
public environmentally triggered chronic
illness so they're just giving this data
to the commission that's doing the study
so if that helps
thank you okay I misunderstood that that
makes more sense okay
sorry a representative goalie you had a
question
yes I think
so
is it
the information that's
currently available online in your
portal
that this memorandum understanding
allows you to transfer over to Des or is
there other information Des is giving to
Health and Human Services that's in this
memorandum
thank you representative goalie um I we
would defer a little bit to Karen Craver
who's here from Des on the Des
information but my understanding is all
of their information is publicly
available on their website
and uh we share uh collaboratively
information that would inform as
representative McGuire said both the
work of the HB 737 commission and
network of the SB 85 commission looking
at Health impacts and uh related to
toxic chemicals so we do share
information between agencies we're asked
to do reporting to those commissions and
a lot of times we collaborate on those
reports to better inform the legislature
on what's happening with pfas and its
related Health impacts
thank you okay representative
thank you madam chair
I think the committee questions that
we're we're trying to understand is this
specific to just Merrimack is it
specific to the entire State and what
kind of
deep down data if I go to your website
right now will I find will I find it by
address will I find it by
um is it is it just
for the entire town is it specific to a
geographic area
how are you tracking that so
you're you're you have medical
diagnosis information
by what category or parameter thank you
so all of the data that's available on
the DHHS website is aggregated so that
you're protect so that there is no
protected health information that's
provided on the website and it's the
data that and I wish I I wish I could
call it up right now because I could
speak to it a little bit better but this
data would not be considered a protected
health information so you won't you
won't find an address or you won't find
you know personally identifiable
information on our website it would be
aggregated uh by it I think that and and
I apologize that I don't know this off
the top of my head I think it might be
census tract at as as the lowest
um
yeah I have to I'd have to go I
apologize I I would have to refer to the
actual data sets to look at that but
this is all public publicly available
data that
um you know the department can share
both with agencies and with other uh
interested parties as well and it is
available on our website
thank you follow on follow-up
representative a bear where your
questions are straying away from the
bill in question
do you have a specific Bill related
question I was just curious about the
first question I asked if it was just
Merrimack specific it is not Merrimack
specific else all the data if you glance
at the data that representative Murphy's
gave us they talk about
various environmental issues and public
health issues throughout the state it's
not Miramax acidic thank you for the
question I just wanted to clarify that
the data that that we share informs a
commission HB 737 which focuses on
Merrimack in the surrounding area SB 85
is a studies chronically triggered
illness and the information that we
collect at DHHS and share with these
commissions is Statewide data but
specifically because the HB 737
commission covers Merrimack Litchfield
Londonderry and surrounding communities
we do focus on those communities for
that Commission because that's the focus
of the commission but but the
information the data shared in the
referenced here is Statewide data that
that um that is requested to from the
Department
okay
represent Gould
thank you madam chair
my question goes to the parameters of
shared data so the question is if this
information is available on your website
then Des can just go to your website and
get it but in your last statement it
sounded like no you tailored the data
for a specific commissions that's kind
of embedded in what this bill
impacts and my other my so a
relationship
could you let them answer your first
question
okay
so I I believe
um so I believe what you're asking is
the data that's on the website do we
have additional data that we inform the
commissions am I understanding that
correctly I didn't really phrase the
question yet what is the question then
thank you madam chair my question is is
the data sharing agreement simply a
piece of paper writing a report and
sharing it or are we talking about your
sharing data between systems and forming
a data set that that helps do something
else
so in so I'll just speak in practice and
practice the Departments work very
closely together on whatever issues that
may arise so they could be commission
related requests it could be or
commission related discussions
um it could be just working together on
other environmental health related
issues and we work pretty closely with
each other all the time regardless of
whether there is an mou in place it is
our common practice to work together
it's our common practice to share
Statewide data with respect to the
specific commissions we have
representation on both commissions so
the Department of Environmental Services
and the Department of Health and Human
Services are members of those
commissions of The Chronic the
environmentally triggered chronic
disease as well as the Merrimack pfas
related commissions so we work closely
with commission members we work closely
with each other and we certainly would
share information with respect to Sports
we we work collaboratively on the
development of those reports and
oftentimes those are reports are are
providing information to the commission
on what the Departments have done over
the past period of time relative to
either pfas or relative to other
environmentally triggered chronic
disease concerns and so we have sort of
a running list of items that we report
back to the commissions on as we have
participated in those discussions on the
commission and and that is a pretty
regular practice the mou sort of
memorializes that but it's really
practice that we would do anyway so if
that's helpful
follow up
so specifically the data share does not
talk you're not talking about pooling
data and creating a database of pool
data between Des and your department I'm
currently each department has a its own
databases
um but certainly sharing data across
agencies helps inform whatever the topic
of re of you know consideration is you
know the data that we have that might be
relevant to the issue at hand versus the
data that Des has but no we aren't
currently pursuing a combined database
if that's the question yeah
thank you representative Schmidt
thank you manager so these two
commissions are they are both ongoing
how often do they meet
I believe they both meet on a monthly
basis
and I know that they um
have a few more years left in terms of
their term
thank you for the question uh they are
for your commissions and there's two
years left two years left in there
thank you they already have a sunset
excellent
other representative true
thank you madam chair
and thank you for taking my question
does this feel this no does this bill
have you do something new that you're
not doing now
so I
I would say that the reporting
requirements the one reporting
requirement would would be to share the
report with the um uh the Merrimack
commission the Merrimack pfas commission
we refer to it as HB 737 it's the um the
terminology here but so that that would
be a new element and changing the
reporting frequency to one year as
opposed to every six months would also
be somewhat new we already do the
reporting as it is it would be a change
in the reporting frequency and then
sharing that report with the other
commission the Merrimack Commission
I just wanted to add in for some
background as in uh when the data
sharing agreement language was put in
the bill by representative Pearson in
to put it in statute the DHHS and Des
would its statute be required to share
data as Michelle has already said we've
always that's always been our standard
practice I think there were some
Community concerns related to
communities that have been affected by
pfas and the potential Health impacts
and it just was something that was put
forward to make sure that it was a
requirement so those communities could
be reassured that this work is ongoing
so that's just some background that I
wanted to share with you
thank you madam chair and and did I hear
you say I don't know if you were talking
about uh an agreement or understanding
that it must lapse so it can be reviewed
so I can speak a little bit to that so
the terminology that's currently in
statute and in the proposed bill is
um a memorandum of agreement and the
Department's understanding is is that
the term memorandum of agreement and
memorandum of understanding are
interchangeable but I do want to inform
the commission that the division of
administrative Services has recently
developed its Manual of procedures or
modified its Manual of procedures
referred to as mop and specifically
there is a a standard out there a number
161 that refers to the terminology of
memorandum of of understanding along
with some formatting requirements
associated with any
memorandums of understanding between
agencies as representative Nancy Murphy
mentioned during her testimony
um
for consistency
if the commission if the committee would
would like you could revise the language
of memorandum of agreement that's in in
the statue in the proposed Bill to
memorandum of understanding because that
is the language that the depart
Department of administrative Services is
currently using that being said as I
noted both of those terms are used
interchangeably
um and and the department is currently
working with the Department of
Environmental Services on revising
um the memory revising the Moa and we
currently have a draft as an mou so
we're working through that using the
current
um division of style exactly
I have a question so
with both of these
commissions that are looking at
environmental health
expiring in two years should your
memorandum of agreement and this
reporting requirement also end
I guess I can speak to the reporting
requirement I think that if the
commission no longer exists we wouldn't
be able to report out to that commission
so I think that that is a
a reasonable understanding okay
other questions
all right
does anyone else wish to testify on
House Bill 391
okay I don't see one
I'll close the public hearing
and I believe representative Burr this
is going to your subcommittee
doing something
yes because it sounds like they need to
foreign
and I'd like to open up the public
hearing on hb366 and welcome back
representative Gallagher
if
so hi I'm Eric Gallagher
um
for
people who missed my previous
introduction I'm representing uh
Meramec County District 20 that's
conquered Ward 6.
um so I am here
to introduce
house bill
366 prohibiting certain non-compete
causes and non-disclosure agreements
regarding free software projects and the
sharing of Open Source software
um so
some of you who were on this
committee last term
um
may remember that
last term
um
I had
a bill
come before
this committee uh House Bill 1273 that I
called my software act which is an
acronym for securing our freedom to
write and read everything
so
um
part of the reason
that bill died was because the committee
determined that I was trying to do too
much in a single bill so
um
but I think I do remember some of you
saying that there were some good parts
in it so I decided to
try breaking it apart into
several bills this year
to see if
the bill as a hall can't pass then maybe
at least hunt the individual parts
uh can pass
so
um this one is the part specifically
about non-compete clauses and
non-disclosure agreements
um
so
uh not non-competed agreements or
something
that have
been growing in unpopularity
over recent years
they're basically
ways of
for
companies
to prevent
their employees from doing things
um
so uh yeah I come from the free and open
source software community and oftentimes
you'll
hear
the in the free and open source software
Community you'll hear
um
developers from proprietary software
companies
saying that
they can't help on such a such an issue
because something in their contract so
um
yeah
um use
you see uh there there has been other
legislation to restrict non-competes
in New Hampshire
previously I think some for low-income
workers uh
and then another I think for last term
was
um
about public health regulations
releasing uh
people from non-competes in those cases
um
so the um Biden Administration
has actually been
considering
um breaking out the big hammer and just
um ending non-competes entirely
like every single type
um
so that's not what this bill does this
bill is
just focused on the ones uh that would
prevent
software developers from contributing to
free and open source software projects
um
because that's what I have a particular
interest in
um
but um
yeah I I would be open to going bigger
um if that's something that there's
interest in
um
so
yeah why why do this at the state level
if
um there's also changes coming at the
national level well I think it's good
just kind of as a backup uh the buy
administration's plan is to do so by
administrative rule making
which
um
isn't quite as permanent uh
executive branch rulemaking can often
change whenever there's a new president
um and Things by
statute are
a bit firmer
um
so
and yeah I think just to signal that New
Hampshire
is a welcoming place for
software developers from the free and
open source software Community to come
um live and work
I think
it helps us as a state
uh
to have this legislation now
when I brought this legislation
uh here last term
uh
one of the
questions I got was uh about
security concerns
um
so
I added a closet at this time around to
uh make an
exception for National Security to make
sure that
um
people yeah people can't
violate our national security
with this legislation
um
so yeah it's basic
so to address one possible
Point
um
some people might say that
well
copyright law
is the federal domain so we shouldn't be
trying to do it at the state level well
so this isn't really copyright law per
se this is at the intersection of
copyrights and contracts and contracts
are something we do have
um
a
say in here at the state level so it's
basically saying
when there's a conflict
between
a
free software license
and either a non-competing agreement or
a non-disclosure agreement then the free
software license wins and the state
shall not enforce
that other agreement
um
so yeah this is basically
let just legislation to
um
help out the free software Community
here in New Hampshire and I'll take any
questions on it now
yeah
are there any questions
representative leckis
thank you so um
you know I I worked in software
engineering for over 40 years in both
proprietary and
free and open software but I there's a
section here that I'd like some
clarification on because I don't know
precisely what it's referencing it says
starting line 18
can prevent an employee from sharing the
source code of free and open lice
assault I'm sorry free and open source
software that such employee would
otherwise normally be able to share
under the license what precisely is that
referring to
so basically like
if the if the um
software's license statement that's how
ignore software normally comes with
source code comes with license States
and it's in it
um oftentimes they will say explicitly
you have the freedom to copy this
um so
um
yeah and that that applies to most
normal people
um so it's basically if that person were
not an employee at that company
um and we're operating solely based on
that license
um if the license says you may share
this then it's basically saying then the
license is right and you may actually
share this
follow-up
um I mean if you just
got some free or open source software
and used it and then
um you know sharing it doesn't really
mean anything because it's already out
there
in public domain are you talking about a
situation where the employee took this
free and open source software modified
it and then wants to share the result is
is that what you're getting at uh yeah
that's more along the lines of yeah if
they want to make contributions back
Upstream as they call it in the software
world they're allowed um Upstream
referring to the project that's
developing that software then they can
do that as well
thank you excuse me representative
Gallagher are you saying that you
that you encourage
visuals to modify this software on their
employees their employers time and then
give it away
uh this doesn't say anything about being
on their time or not this is like when
they go home
um and
uh sometimes employers will
claim rights over what their employees
do in their free time as well besides
just
um the things that they do on Company
hours uh so this is
to um
this this is more about things that uh
the employees do in their free time
thank you I don't know how how the state
would ever be able to enforce that well
if I if I may respond this is more about
the state not enforcing it something
it's about the state not enforcing the
contract so it wouldn't require to say
actively doing anything it would just
require the state saying no I'm not
actually going to enforce that but yeah
anyways
thank you representative O'Brien thank
you madam chairman thank you
representative Gallagher for taking my
question
um I'm glad you mentioned on line 21 the
National Security needs but I'm very
fearful with the uh the baby booms the
Aging everything else like that and
you've brought up the term upstreaming
what's to stop somebody of Nefarious
means from upstreaming a virus and then
passing it out and then future can uh
contamination it seems that's handled
within the corporate world but if
somebody individual that's nefarious it
could be open Prairie
so in the free and open source software
world we have something that's called
The Many Eyes principle where basically
the more people look at the code for
something the greater the chance is that
they'll find vulnerabilities
in it so
um yeah if somebody wanted to
uh try to contribute malware to the
Upstream of a free and open source
software project then
the
most projects that run like this have
software review practices in place
already to catch things like that
um so I think it would be
handled in the normal way
like that
other questions representative Bailey
thank you
um
this is probably somewhat dated but
years ago I was told that Unix was open
source right and that the various other
things Red Hat this and Linux that were
they were using the open source but they
had put in a couple of proprietary
things that were their own that they
could then sell
an open source thing and then if you
were working
one of these proprietary companies
that's making their own modifications
and then went
onto the some kind of Unix form and
there's some information there that's
proprietary that you should not be
sharing right
well yeah so yeah there are companies
like red hat and IBM that work both in
the uh free software world and in the
proprietary software World
um and
so yeah part um
so part of the thing to remember here is
the definition of free software uh so
we're talking about free software in the
sense of freedom of preserving the users
freedoms so one of the freedoms that
free software comes with is the freedom
to sell it so
um
yeah uh companies companies like red hat
the the
their software
um yeah sometimes they do sell software
that the source is already available for
and the way they're able to make money
off of that is because it's through
things like support contracts and
um you know they'll be in the position
of saying all right
so where we'll we'll help you with it if
it breaks it because
um
you know the where we we actually
understand it and um can provide you
with documentation
on how to actually use it so um
yeah uh
I
I I don't think that this legislation
would prevent companies from doing that
sort of thing
thank you
other questions
all right thank you very much
representative Gallagher
Dennis Goulet
te
good morning I'm Adam chair members of
the committee uh for the record my name
is Dennis Goulet I'm the commissioner
for the Department of Information
Technology I'm here to testify in
opposition to this bill today
um I would start out by
observing that the the language is is
quite expansive and I think it would be
um there are a lot of cases where it
would be difficult to determine whether
it applied or not so here's that that
starts out with a pretty large challenge
there and I'm going to take you through
a kind of a state government perspective
and then the larger State perspective uh
on this and coming from uh just coming
from a background of I spent almost my
entire career in the software industry
either as an I.T person or a running
commercial software development projects
as well as open source development
projects so I have a lot of experience
in this space and the IP intellectual
property space
um
so from a state perspective we actually
contractually in most cases hold
proprietary interest in the software
that we pay to develop so for example
um you know if we have a specific uh
piece of software and another state
wanted to use it for example a lot of
times we'll negotiate with the state and
most times it you know we share it but
that software may or may not have open
source libraries built into it
but we maintain at least today uh that
you know if we developed something say
for HHS or whatever they that they'd
hold proprietary interest in it and
event the vendor who developed it for us
would not necessarily be able to go and
reuse it or the or the intellectual
property associated with using those
open source libraries
um the other thing is is agencies
multiple agencies will have regulatory
challenges we often write into contracts
and HHS is kind of the the grand the
great granddaddy of this where because
of the types of data that we're managing
the having having openness with respect
to any aspects of the the
um of the the product itself or the
software that we're using to run the
state business is is problematic so
sharing of
sharing of Open Source Code in the
context of a larger State application
could be pretty problematic from a
security and privacy perspective and
I'll talk more a little about the uh the
many eyes principle at the end
so there's fundamental ambiguity in in
the case of of uh the you know trying to
differentiate between a company holding
proprietary interest in software and
this this language
um the two cases I think of you I heard
you discussed one of them earlier which
was companies that that actually Market
you know open source um uh Linux Unix we
actually the state runs hundreds of
instances of of Linux for example and we
we do pay for support and uh so there's
open source Linux out there and then
there's Linux where a an employee of a
company may have proprietary interest in
what they're doing and that's
fundamentally ambiguous the other
ambiguity is that many many products
whether they're ones we're running in
the state or um
or or commercial software products have
open source libraries in them now I've
signed not signed and lived under
non-disclosure agreements pretty much
until I came to New Hampshire seven and
a half years ago as the CIO and um
you know it it never harms me but I
understood that you know particularly
when I was in the engineering side of
these products that the the open source
libraries are in context with the
intellectual property that was developed
and invested in by that company so I
would argue that the the company does
have a right to proprietary interest in
that
now recently from a cyber security
perspective that has caused a lot of
problems the log 4J incident if you look
that up that that's causing caused us un
uncounted hours of effort trying to find
all the places where that you know that
open source Library exists so on you
know on the one hand where you know it
was nice to have that open source
Library built into a product on the
other hand it did in fact create some
pretty significant security
vulnerabilities that are well documented
in in the in the world
um the
the
what I wrote up in the fiscal note
really was more of taking a broader
perspective of you know there was a
question that came up is how would we
you know regulate or adjudicate this I
would argue that
um because of the ambiguity and the
expansiveness of it it would be it would
be pretty challenging to um to do so and
I think an entity would have to be
established to do that at probably at
the state level the other thing I would
argue is that
um you know because we're gonna you know
we are trying to chip away at this idea
of proprietary interest in New Hampshire
I think that it you know from take going
to the other side of my career
um you know if I were in an executive in
a software company I said do I want to
locate in New Hampshire and create jobs
in New Hampshire I I'd be thinking twice
about it if I was perceiving the state
as unfriendly to proprietary interest in
technology finally the the many eyes
principle is one from a cyber security
perspective I've heard it twice today
probably going to hear it some more
because these you know is rep Gallagher
indicated
um the um that was one bill with a bunch
of stuff in it now it's a whole bunch of
different bills they're the other side
of the many eyes principle is that it's
it's it's easy every software has
vulnerabilities every every piece and um
so even if it goes through review I've
you know I've done commercial software
development multiple layers of review
we've still we've still published
software with vulnerabilities being able
to look and see and find those
vulnerabilities as a as a a criminal or
somebody with Mal intent is inherently
much easier in an open source context
than it is in a um in a proprietary
context so that's the other side of that
coin but I do agree in in the open
source world it's pretty self-regulating
for the most part so I I think you could
manage an open source context and still
produce software that was at least as
good as what you do in a proprietary
context that that uh concludes my formal
testimony I'm happy to take questions
uh no I'm noticing a stunned look so uh
we may get back to you later
thank you very much
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill 366.
all right seeing none I will close the
public hearing foreign
yes okay without objection so I'd like
to make a motion of itl on House Bill
366.
thank you is there a second second
representative goalie
okay would you like to speak to your
motion uh I would so I'm actually a uh
you know I think open source software is
a great thing I've both been a user of
it and done work to contribute to it
um so that's not the issue and and some
of the concerns about it I think were
overstated but
um I'm opposed to this for two reasons
one is I am let's just say very
reluctant to uh interfere in in private
contracts including you know employment
contracts
um so that would probably you know seal
my position in and of itself the other
issue is that um
and I mean the real there's a lot of
stuff talk about open source software
that I don't think this really applies
to the main thing was um
you know if you can get the source code
anybody can get the source code for open
source software you can make changes to
it and then you can provide it back to
the open source community and and it can
kind of be reviewed and they decide
whether to incorporate it in in that and
so everybody could use it and the issue
is if you're an employee at a company
and you're doing you're doing this then
there's two issues one is it really on
your time or the employer's time I think
that's actually the Lesser problem but
it is is an issue the other thing is is
that
in the work you're doing at the company
there's
um
ideas uh Concepts
um you know things that you learn and
are develop paid for by the company as
part of that
and you know you're likely going to
whether you mean to or not going to
incorporate that into the changes you
make to this software that you're you're
releasing to the whole world and so
you know you're both taking you're
almost certainly taking
something the employers paid for and
basically giving it away and potentially
more
um and and that's you know you can't
adjudicate that means unless somebody's
like blatant just steals a bunch of code
and sticks it in it which they'd be
foolish to do I mean it's really hard to
tell whether that's really what's going
on or not and uh so given that as much
as I I strongly support open source
software I think it's a great thing
um and I might even encourage employers
to
you know that they might attract I mean
an employer if they can attract better
or more potential employees by not
having this non-compete in then it's in
their business interest to do it uh but
I don't think it's our place to tell
them they can't and because there are
potential problems for the employer so
that's it
thank you representative goalie do you
just speak to your second
uh no I think representative Lucas uh
spoke some to some of the concerns I had
thank you okay
anyone else comments questions
discussion
all right seeing none the motion is
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
366 by representative seconded barabena
goalie and the clerk can call the rule
representative Simon yes
representative Lucas yes representative
Bailey yes representative Santo nastasso
yes representative true yes
representative Dolan yes
representative Weber yes
the clerk votes yes
representative groda yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative shewitt yes
representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes and the chair
yes
the vote 18 yay Serenade all right the
motion passes is there any objection to
consent
all right seeing none we'll put this on
okay and that closes
House Bill 366. we we will resume at 1
15 on house bills 327.
don't get scared
it's me mistake it's only 17-0
please uh correct your your memories of
what will said
Gearhart stepped out to to testify on
another committee
welcome back
I'm opening the hearing on House Bill
327 and calling on representative
Gallagher
foreign
representative for Merrimack County
District 20 which is Concord Ward 6.
um
so I am here this time to introduce
House Bill 327 prohibiting the state
from requiring
members of the public to use proprietary
software when visiting State websites
um
so
this kind of ties in with my previous
one I'll
repeat I'll be repeating myself a little
bit just for anyone who's only tuning in
now
um but
anyways so this was part of
uh
last years
House Bill 1273
which I referred to as my software act
an acronym for securing our freedom to
write and read everything
um
basically uh it was an Omnibus
about promoting software freedom in the
state of New Hampshire
um
and
one of the EXO it came before this
committee last term and one of the
pieces of feedback
I got about it was what it was trying to
do too much in a single bill so I
uh took that advice to heart or that
feedback to heart and uh
Lewis split it into
several different bills so that way
we could confirm consider all of the
individual parts
separately to
um
see see just which of those
the individual parts that were actually
kind of good were
um so
um this one
specifically is about State websites
um
so
this is basically
um
the bill calling for Libra JS
compatibility on
State websites
um
so it says it's got kind of some tricky
wording
it talks about
um not requiring
users to allow the
execution of proprietary JavaScript so
that means um
that that means
that basically it just has to have a
graceful fallback for
uh when the user
is browsing with an extension like Libra
JS enabled or with JavaScript disabled
entirely so and
um
the reason for this
asked outlined um
in an article called the JavaScript trap
is because when there are
uh proprietary pieces of JavaScript on
websites they can uh they they violate
users freedoms to be browsing the web
they want to they can insert tracking
data and or tracking tags to collect
data to send to private companies
um so
this would basically just be giving the
users
freedom to
disable that
um
so
and the idea
the idea is this should just be for
um
interactions with the state that are
legally required like
um
so
basically ones where the user doesn't
have another way around it because they
have to interact with the state through
the website
um
so and um yeah the language
is
pretty much the same as
it appeared in um
last year's Bill except
there is
there is one minor difference
um there was an and that changed to I
changed to an or just to give between so
they can either the department of it can
either
use a browser extension like Libra JS I
didn't say that specifically because I
didn't want to preference a single
organization's work but so if they can
find another one that does the same
thing they could also use that
or by confirming that no proprietary
JavaScript blocks the functioning of any
third-party online
archiving services so like the Wayback
machine on the internet archive
we have web pages if New Hampshire State
web pages
render properly when
uh loaded in the internet archive then
they would pass this test so
um they can do either one or the other
it's their choice on how to verify it
and I think this would be
a good way
of
helping to
give back to
users some of the freedom of
to control
their
experiences when interacting with the
state and if that all
take questions now
representative Gallagher I'm
confused because you
you could limit it to only those
transactions or interactions that are
legally required it's not in the bill
but that's what you said oh that or that
was my intent
um I okay
that's your intent I that's fine my
question is what
web transactions are required
well
um like
if you could always avoid them by uh
going out in person and meeting whoever
it is you want to want to deal with
well I
um I mean that might be the case now but
I'm thinking of like if we move to say
an all online tax payment system or
um or Court appearances or school work
for
like kid kids in public schools have to
do their schoolwork
for
so this is
essentially not
a preemptive strike against some future
situation that may or may not exist in
the present
or maybe avoided in the present
is that correct or am I totally am I
missing something
um I I'm not quite sure if you're
correct or not I can't answer that okay
fine does anyone else have a question
representative Bailey
thank you
um have you seen the financial note
um yeah that seems rather that would
have us that seems rather shocking to me
that is more than I would have expected
personally
um
it's almost like you could buy everybody
in the state their own computer company
yeah I I don't know how they calculated
that
all right thank you
anyone else
all right thank you for sure you have a
question I love represent Simon
um oh go ahead
okay
um so you had mentioned uh children
needing to do school work on you know
for school
um I don't see it in the bill but was it
your intention to push that down
potentially to municipalities and school
districts as well as state agencies
um
maybe not with this bill specifically I
guess
um this is kind of the side effect of
having split this bill into multiple
Parts is that
um
I might be confusing some stuff I meant
to do with one of the other bills with
this one
so
um yeah I I don't think that would
actually come into
effect here although I would certainly
appreciate it if they
voluntarily complied with this as well
thank you Brooklyn Gerhard thank you
madam chair I
I actually like the thought behind this
it makes a lot of sense I don't
understand why we have to be giving up
personal data especially when we have
rights privacy in New Hampshire if we're
going online
I don't I don't know the cost though is
insane yeah so if you can get a handle
on that that'd be interesting because
I'm looking at the numbers yeah so
anyway I don't believe that
representative Gallagher could help with
understand the numbers that's uh yeah
okay
anyone else
representative Gould
thank you madam chair
so from understanding this correctly in
circumstances like getting a fire permit
in our town they choose to only use the
online system that the state provides
now
that
taking that action you're saying
is collecting data behind the scenes
that if this bill passed it would allow
us to do things that would let us visit
that site anonymously to not be
collecting other data well I I mean I
don't I or I don't know
um your
specific towns website how it operates
if it has any proprietary JavaScript on
it or not
um I'm sorry it's the State website
State website um yeah
um
so
yeah
um
uh but that but that's the thing about
uh when software is
proprietary is that you just don't know
and you can't really know what exactly
it's doing so the point is
to um
give control
back
into our own hands so that way we can
actually know what all of our software
is doing
thank you thank you madam chair other
questions
all right thank you very much all right
thank you
um
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill 327 represent yes
we'll uh
thank you
good afternoon members of the committee
a reminder I'm Dennis Goulet the
commissioner of the Department of
Information Technology
um
I'll start out a little differently than
I intended and and you know that you
know my testimony really covers the
executive branch and the fiscal note
executive branch only
um but I think the same issues would be
would apply to the um to the other
branches and constitutional offices and
I I am testifying in opposition
um but the ACT executive branch actually
is pretty careful not to collect
information that people aren't aware of
in fact we have a policy in fact
somebody just brought into my attention
the other day and asked me if they could
have an exception on it and I said
probably not
um it's for doing the very things that
that rep Gallagher was talking about
which is the you know the tracking and
the cross-referencing the things that
get create all those situations where
you get extra stuff popping up in your
browser that you didn't really want
there so we don't do that in the
executive branch I don't think it's done
very much at all in in state government
websites but I couldn't speak to the
other uh Parts the
um the so I'll make my testimony simple
and then I'm sure you'll probably have
some questions maybe on the fiscal note
or whatever but there's
you know obviously the the bill itself
to implement this as written would be
very expensive we we put a range in the
in our in our in our calculation
assumptions in the fiscal note and I I
didn't just pull those numbers out of a
hat you know we I talked to people we
looked at recent things that we had done
um there are almost 80 State websites on
the executive branch and there are over
270 applications that are hosted on our
websites to do things that citizens do
like
um you know like tax for example
uh a lot of the some of most of those
applications are vendor applications so
in order to comply with this we would
have to
either induce the vendor to go and do
what what it would take to comply
um which we'd have to pay him to do or
or maybe we'd have to re-procure the app
and so that's one of the one of the
challenging things about that is we'd
have to actually have to look at each
application
um in detail to figure out whether there
was any proprietary JavaScript running
on it and and then cause that to be
remediated now I I in my last job I was
I was in charge of commercial software
development for healthcare I.T and I had
six products
and when I was there and now I could not
tell you whether I had proprietary
JavaScript in them and where it was if
it was there so I would have had to do a
deep dive into you know and one of the
apps had seven million lines of code so
talking a fairly you know fairly
extensive process to get that done
but the cost to me isn't isn't the most
challenging part of this it would be in
order to remediate this I would you know
or to be in compliance I would shift our
efforts away from the program work we're
doing in the agencies to this work
so this work would have to be let's
pretend it's free for a minute this work
would have to be pretty darn important
for us to stop doing what we're we're
doing now and move to other work and uh
and it deep in the in the calculations
of the fiscal note there are some
contract folks there that we would bring
in to help if we had to do it but again
it would it would heavily impact state
labor and again I don't see the benefit
because we're not really doing
um you know we're not tracking we're
being very careful on privacy in fact I
have you know we'll we'll be working on
um I'm trying to get funded in the
budget a Chief privacy officer so I
think we get even better than that
because I think that you know what we're
seeing in States now and I think we
should see in New Hampshire is taking
privacy more seriously instead of doing
it a bit here a bit there have
overriding privacy policies and you know
model ourselves after some of the the
leading privacy advocates in the world
like you see some stuff like you've
probably experienced now when you go
into websites where they tell you
they're going to track you before they
track you you know or they tell you you
know or you have to the default is if
any information is going to travel it's
an opt-in not a you have to go opt out
just little principles like that but
those are principles that are important
to us and um where you know I think
I like the idea I really love the idea
of not taking data from people without
them knowing it and I certainly won't be
advocating for that as as the um
as the um CIO and the commissioner so I
think that concludes my formal testimony
and I'm happy to answer any and all
questions
thank you
um
yeah I I support the idea of what he's
trying to do you know I I worked uh
software engineering for over 40 years
both proprietary and and uh free
software and and I you know my view is
he's right that if you're there that
sort of JavaScript stops running on
someone's system they can't know what
you're collecting or not
um and that's the issue so my question
is I mean the cost is a huge issue and I
can kind of understand where it's coming
from
the question is what would your feeling
be and what would the cost be
if we said going forward any new
application or a major redo of existing
Applications had this requirement
excuse me
um that's that's a good question and uh
you know it isn't in the bill itself but
when I wrote up the the fiscal note I
did
I did write that as as what I considered
a technical flaw because what it would
do is it would
narrow I think it would narrow the field
in terms of who could bid on new stuff
it might narrow it a lot
so that's that would be my the challenge
I think we still we'd still create a a
situation for ourselves which I think
could be managed in other ways
follow-up follow-up what do you mean by
managed in other ways um I think that
what we're seeing in the you know states
that have hired Chief privacy officers
and corporate entities have strong
policies that they Implement and I would
you know if we if we were able to fund a
Chief privacy officer function I would
want their authority to have the force
of law to implement policy in the
executive branch so that we were doing
the right things with technology so it's
uh
from a privacy perspective thank you
anyone else
I was one I worked on the true
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
um can you tell me
what does it mean to prohibit the state
from requiring the public to use the
priority of software when visiting State
websites
and then you answer please consider me
to be a child
or a golden retriever
they just give me an idea of what we're
talking about
sure thing representative true
so
um rep Gallagher kind of talked about it
is if there were a if a um
a user came into a State website
they would be able to to interact with
it in a way that didn't run the software
that this bill precludes
is that
is that understandable
yes
um so and that's why it's it's
challenging because it's it's pretty
expansive yeah what what does
proprietary JavaScript do other I mean I
know the idea but what why would you use
it other than for tracking
um
it's it's been used for a lot of
functionality in in applications it's
it's everywhere um in fact I I you heard
me testify earlier the log 4J uh
security issue that we've been dealing
with
um
we found log 4J libraries everywhere and
we're it's taking us a really long time
to remediate all of them but some of
them are pretty easy to remediate and
others are more difficult
so it's it's very pervasive and it's
used to to implement web functionality
so stuff that's going on in front of you
is often being is often being
implemented via the use of JavaScript
thank you I believe
uh anyone else
represent Gerhard thank you madam chair
I'm a little bit confused though so we
we put into position a Chief privacy
officer but his hands are tied because
we can't really Institute these things
because then people won't bid on new
projects so would it just be better to
just downsize the computer-based aspects
of a lot of this dude I'm trying to get
it it seems like we can't do this unless
we track people and we're giving it to
third parties we don't know what they're
doing with the information I mean
realistically it could be anybody right
this JavaScript whatever is collecting
information and sending it to whoever
theoretically but by policy we preclude
the doing that
and so it's part of our when we procure
Solutions
um we
we procure it with that in mind and that
is part of how we operate and there
there are even further restrictions
depending on what sort of monies are
being used and what the agency is
because there's different rules on that
so Noah if we had a Chief privacy
officer our hands would not be tied I
think they'd be in fact I think they'd
be liberating the limiting the use of
Technology would I mean the technology
density in the state is going up
um is going up because we're using
technology to do things faster we're
doing it to mitigate Workforce
challenges things like that so reducing
the amount of tech we use would reduce
our services to the citizens and
businesses of the state
follow up
so you do know where this information is
being collected and from who to whom
it's going you do have control over that
yes
okay
but it's a problem of trying to stop
that because you have to find it in the
code
that's how I'm a little I'll just I'll
take this offline just figure it out
thank you thank you
anyone else
all right thank you
um thank you for for your testimony is
there anyone else who wishes to testify
okay
in that case I will close the public
hearing
okay
put up time
I want to go into exact session if
that's all right all right without
objection we'll go into exact session
representative it sounds like you have a
motion yep I'd like to make a motion of
itl on House Bill 327 FN second
okay our second Deborah I'm gonna show
it
would you care to speak to your motion
please yes
um
I'd actually like to be able to
OTP this but
because I mean representative Gallagher
raised some real issues you and and you
know I can give a tutorial on this
sometime but basically JavaScript is
software that's comes is downloaded into
your web browser and runs on your
computer
and they can say whatever it does or it
doesn't do but there's no way for you to
know what it's doing on your computer
and that's a concern so the question is
do you trust them or even achieve
protect you know information officer or
whatever but there's two issues one is I
you know I can quibble over as cost
estimates in the FN but I don't think
they're crazy it would be very expensive
for them to do it
um
I I want to know I mean I I could also
see doing an amendment to require it
going forward but even there I think it
would take some investigation to see how
much it really would cost
what would be the consequences
um as far as the functionality of the
website so given all that
for this bill at this point
um I'd say itl although you looking into
something like this in the future might
not be unreasonable
representative shewitt
thank you madam chair
um I agree that the the cost kind of
startled me
um but I understand the testimony from
the I.T Department uh some of the
reasoning behind those but I also was
concerned because the sponsor himself
answered a lot of our questions with I
don't know and it made me think that
this perhaps wasn't thought out quite as
well as it should have been
okay representative Simon
thanks it's kind of actually a question
for representative like us since you
know more about this than I do
um is this something that a personal VPN
would protect you from even with
JavaScript running in the background
would essentially
uh no it wouldn't okay and uh if I may
no please okay uh a little bit in
defense of Representative Gallagher I
think at least some of the I don't knows
is he doesn't know what the websites
State websites are currently doing and
it's reasonable for him not to know that
that's
yeah that's very true
representative O'Brien do you have a
question
anyone else have a question
representative Gerhard thank you madam
chair it just seems for me being a
carpenter it seems like we have this
thing we built this house has asbestos
in it and since we already built it
initially with some asbestos we're going
to keep building more of the house with
asbestos and put on extensions because
going back and getting the asbestos out
is going to be a problem I I don't I
don't know I'm just kind of simplistic
here but it doesn't make any sense why
we couldn't nip this in the bud at least
to stop it from growing more pervasive
so thank you
I I think we ought to write our report
such that we say that we think it is a
concern and that we hope that it will be
considered going forward because we'd
rather not do it
in in the future particularly if we
don't absolutely have to
and we want to know if we are doing it
we'd like to know that
representative leckis yeah just uh uh
briefly on
um previous speaker's point it's
there are a lot of standard tools used
for developing websites a lot of them
use JavaScript and so his statement that
they might find have trouble finding
vendors to to uh to do the work on
websites is at least not unreasonable I
think it would require a fair you know
fair amount of Investigation looking
into options and what the cost would be
before it would be responsible to say
you know they can't do this going
forward or we have to change the
existing ones or whatever
okay thank you anyone else
okay in that case the motion is
inexpected to legislate on House Bill
327 by representative blackis and the
clerk can call the rule
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey
yes
representative Santo nastasso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative Weber yes
representative Gerhard
yes
the clerk will Jess
representative groda yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative schuett yes
representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes and the chair
yes
in 18 yay zero nay
okay 18 18-0 the motion passes and the
objections to consent
all right thank you we will put this one
on consent Madam chair yes if I can just
add I I didn't mean to imply that
um
the sponsor drafted the bill badly but
rather that there were aspects of some
of the things that were asked about say
municipalities that he hadn't thought of
that was all oh okay so noted
nope all right
okay and we have until 2 P.M
for our last hearing of the day
all right so next week we've got
Wednesday Thursday
I tried to get all the software together
on one day so we'd only have we could
forget it after tomorrow
okay
all right it is two o'clock I'm opening
the hearing on House Bill 230 and I call
Representative Bixby
thank you madam chair uh
for the record I'm representative Peter
Bixby from Dover and the ranking member
of House environment and agriculture
uh so
uh the bill before you uh
the the my initial uh recognition of its
need came last fall when it was uh on a
soil soil conditioner study committee
and we were hearing testimony from uh
the department on uh fertilizer
standards and uh one of the things that
director Wyman noted was that uh there
was a significant drain on his staff
time because uh the lack of the lack of
Technology uh he has a lot of his staff
are doing hand data entry instead of
doing things like performing testing on
uh on fertilizers and other regulated
products and
um
so this seemed like a you know something
that needed to be dealt with and the
best way would be to provide the
technology to the Department of AG
markets agriculture markets and Foods
and I discussed it with the department
and they said uh it actually made more
sense to rather than making it narrowly
associated with fertilizers uh make it a
request from the Department to
establish a data handling system that
would basically take care of all of
their uh needs for licensing and
registrations and and other data that
could be easily submitted online
but is currently submitted on paper
so
uh the uh and one of the points is that
that lack of Technology wastes a lot of
Staff time in
um in all of their divisions and uh you
know it would be much better to have
trained staff people who know what
they're doing with regulation dealing
with things like analyzing products and
doing inspections when they're needed uh
doing the inspections that are actually
called for in state law as opposed to
occasionally doing them when there is a
complaint filed
so um
the other another aspect of this is that
the lack of Technology makes Department
Services more difficult for the people
who are being regulated uh if you have
to fill things out on paper
the uh rather than submitting online it
is uh more it's a more tedious process
and you don't get the results of your
registration as soon so uh
a product registration can go through
much more quickly if it were simple
simply submitted online and uh so uh
there are also implications for the
businesses that are regulated because if
you're waiting for you know you know
weeks or months for something to get
processed rather than a week or two then
that delays when you can start acting on
what you're registering
uh so
um
the department now has an I.T person uh
that was brought on as uh in because of
the animal database bill that we passed
that passed through the budget last term
uh and that person has been able to uh
put together some not the well he was
the person who put together the uh the
numbers uh in the fiscal note
um and uh he's mentioned that there are
potentially significant efficiencies by
using the same vendor for this project
as uh is being used for the animal
database product project
um the fiscal note indicates the cost
between uh 360
000 uh to 500 000 for the initial
establishment of the database uh the 360
000 that is in the bill was what was
quoted to me when I uh was talking with
the Department last fall on during
filing period uh if it seems that the if
it turns out the slightly higher than
six three hundred sixty thousand dollar
appropriation is needed then it would
still be appropriate I think it would be
appropriate to you know provide the
amount of money needed because in terms
of long-term savings and staff time and
inefficiency uh that initial upfront
capital investment uh it will pay off
significantly
uh and there's an annual maintenance
cost of about 200 000 uh and this cost
Falls within the range of the fee income
from registrations and Licensing and uh
it would clearly be an appropriate use
of existing fees so that would not
require any further uh ongoing
appropriation uh and the state has
currently has a surplus a budget surplus
so this would be a good time for this
sort of capital investment
and I'm happy to take any questions
thank you very much I do have one
general question why is it why is this
not in the budget does it
well um that would be a question for uh
commissioner Jasper because he had the
option of putting in the budget and
um he's asked me to put the bill in I
did approach the governor yesterday and
said and said I had this bill it might
make sense to go into the budget and he
said send it to me I'll have a look at
it so it may go into the budget but
um in the meantime uh it it's something
that's is it's important to have it move
forward so whichever path it takes
um that it I'd like to see it happen
thank you other questions representative
O'Brien thank you madam chair thank you
representative Bixby for taking my
question
uh I like to describing things
particularly when a pillow forms with uh
with the clerk and stuff like that it
seems sometimes a lot of questions get
asked and answered uh particularly if
there's like uh if the clerk has a
problem with my filing okay when you do
electronically you file it and they can
deny it is there any form of appeal or
built into this or any way that a person
can come in and explain his point of
view I I I assume there would be because
the the point of this is simply is so
that
um
the level of design that is stated in
this bill basically means that the
um the department and the vendor set set
forward there you know in their RFP what
they're going to require and based on my
experience with the Department of
Agriculture they're good about
being accessible to the people who they
provide services for so if a person has
a question about what they're filming
out online I'm sure that they could call
the department and get clarification
about what needs to happen
thank you representative Simons
thank you madam chair
um my question has to do with the 196
000 maintenance fees you said that that
would come out of fees um that the
department would collect for those new
fees no those are existing fees so there
is currently there are fees on uh the
product registrations for fertilizer for
lime uh and also there is a tonnage fee
for both of those products uh there are
also fees uh registration fees for pet
food products for
um or and other animal feed products
there are registration fees for
pesticides and
um I'm probably I'm sure I'm missing
various products that they that they
have registrations for but those are
existing registration fees and currently
the fertilizer uh the proceeds of the
fertilizer fees uh runs I'm
it's been about it's been four months
since I looked at the numbers but um I'm
I'm if I'm thinking I'm remembering
something like six hundred thousand
dollars per year comes in uh from the
fertilizer registration fees and that
cover end that at this point goes into
the general fund uh I have another bill
that says it should go into a dedicated
fund but that's that's coming into a
different committee so you don't need to
worry about that but that but the
terminology but if that other bill
passes one of the things that that bill
specifies is that it would be available
for this purpose
thank you representative O'Brien thank
you madam chair
um and thank you representative picture
final one uh as with all software it
comes with licensing agreements so is
your class based upon the initial just
for the software and will it incur
futuristic re-licensing of the product
uh so um the uh the way that the
commissioner explained it to me was that
uh and and he can explain it to you a
little bit further what once he fills
out his pick card but
um the way he explained it to me was
that uh there was an initial cost for
the event they're going to secure a a
third-party vendor to do both the uh and
the the construction of the uh system
and to do ongoing maintenance so uh so
the uh that the 360
um or or so uh is for that initial
establishment of the database and then
there would be an annual contract with
the venue vendor or I'm not sure what
the terms of it might be you know I'm
not sure what the renewal terms of the
con of that contract would be but there
is a long-term contract with a vendor to
continue the upkeep of it
experience other representative Dolan
and then like us
thank you madam chair uh thank you
representative for taking my question as
I look at the appropriation
in the fiscal note of 360
000 that to me is a lot of money
and
um
I'm sorry
the appropriation of a requests in the
fiscal note of 360
000 for this initial purchase seems like
a lot of money to me uh what do do I
read should I read anything into the
fact that there are no other and
legislative endorsements either in the
house or the senate for this expenditure
uh no uh this was primarily I I I put
this bill in as a department request and
uh the
um in terms of what that what is being
purchased for that 360 thousand dollars
uh it what is being purchased is the
available staff time is many many uh
full-time equivalents of Staff time uh
that are currently being used by as on
as data entry which can be used for
skilled
skilled work which is what those people
should be doing and there are
there are a number of statutory
requirements which are being done at a
bare minimum at best because the staff
timing is being occupied by the uh by
doing data entry uh and so what we're
doing with that 360
000 is we are buying a lot of Staff time
thank you other questions representative
thank you um so looking at lines nine
and ten you have in their authorized
users shall be capable of working in
offline mode when an internet connection
is not available I mean that's kind of
an unusual requirement and it might add
to the cost the whole thing is there
some specific aspect of how this is used
or the users that would require that yes
so uh because a number of the people who
are registering uh products or licensing
may be in areas that are not well served
by internet uh
the the that that we feel that that
would um that that would be uh a an
important aspect to have available uh
and uh this that mechanism has was
employed uh in or will be employed in
the animal records database uh for which
it was even more important because you
have you you sometimes you know a
veterinarian may be doing a licensing of
or an inspection of an animal in a place
where in an absolute dead zone and we
have a lot of dead zones in the rural
parts of the State uh so uh in order to
make sure that everybody who is
um
who would need to have access to this
would not be impeded by occasional inter
internet deficiencies uh that was that
was the logic behind putting that in
okay thank you
the quotient
thank you very much representative
uh by commissioner Jasper
good afternoon Madam chairman members of
the committee I am Sean Jasper
commissioner of the Department of
Agriculture markets and food come over
to the to the department and I can
welcome you to the 1980s technology we
deploy in and I'm quite serious about
about that our weights and measures
program was actually uh
developed by a sex offender at the New
Hampshire State Prison in 1984.
um and there's no longer any support for
that
system so uh it's about to crash and
burn and we may not even be able to wait
for this and we have
tried for five years there was a
contract to replace that was awarded
before I became commissioner
um and unfortunately uh
they didn't realize what they were
getting into and I can't take any blame
because I wasn't there but there was
certainly a lack of communications about
what was going on there and we were
trying to straighten that out but that
will be an additional cost to the
contract if we can do it through the
contractor what we're trying to do here
is is bring the rest of the department
into the 20th century my
my joke and it's only partially a joke
since I became commissioner somewhat
over five years ago was that by the time
I retired I'd hoped to bring us into the
1990s
this bill would actually help us get to
where we need to be
we have the animal
um
database that was approved and that that
we still don't know what it's going to
be that's funded through our
um our own funds I think it we expect it
may be as high as a million dollars but
why the rest of this could be more
effective is we took the extra time in
writing
that proposal which is now live it just
went live I think last week or the week
before we put into that request
um the requirements that we have for the
rest of the department so that should
make it much more cost effective and I
understand what people say you know this
is a lot of money but there are six
different divisions in the department
with different needs although some of
them the same ways and weights and
measures is is substantially different
but our I.T lead is here to testify he's
embedded in the department that finally
happened and I suspect this is why we
are still in some cases in the 1980s we
were sort of left out there to dry by
ourselves no one in the department being
an expert in I.T and while doit you know
helped us along they were doing nothing
really to help us prepare for the future
they were just dealing with our
immediate needs for computers and
laptops and and things like that and not
saying hey you really need to get on
board and no one else knew what was what
was going on so having an I.T lead has
made a difference we
I won't say We'll lay anybody off
because that's not going to happen but
we will be able to do more of what the
legislature has asked us to do when I
became commissioner uh
commissioner Merrill told me we were in
triage mode
I soon realized just how true that was
we've moved away from that to a degree
but if I look at all of the statutory
requirements that the legislature has
placed upon us we are far from where we
should be in freeing up staff time is
Key to that I don't want to go out and
hire more people
particularly until I understand what our
needs actually are when we have the
proper technology in place and so this
is imperative for us to uh to get up to
speed and get out of the 1980s
glad to answer any questions that I can
but the technical guy is behind me and
will be testifying next okay thank you
representative Gould
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question can you tell us what
portion of the economy in New Hampshire
is uh does farming and agriculture
contribute to
I can't tell you I can't tell you that
there hasn't been a study on that in in
years
um all told it's a rather large sector
of the economy what I can tell you is
that the Department of Agriculture
does not take from the general fund now
we put money in we have some that stays
in our funds but when you look at the
total revenues that we generate
we run between 200 000 and somewhat over
a million dollars a year positive so we
are a we're not asking really for money
from the general fund we're asking for
money that we have put into the general
fund so that we can do a better job with
what you've asked us to do thank you
follow-up follow-up
so um
so this
this is a this represents services to a
major portion of contributing
um workers in our state to the economy
and and what I'm hearing is that
allowing them to be able to do this
remotely and not have to go into the
office
would be a convenience for for farmers
and
largely what happens is they're not
coming in they're sending us paper
okay and then we're taking that paper
and we've got somebody there typing
things in
um you know terrible waste of Human
Resources when things should be
automatically entered rather than the
people filling out paper forms
we want them to be able to put it in
directly online and take out all of that
unnecessary work it doesn't take them
any more time takes us a lot more time
so
yes
other questions representative
thank you um
so I don't come close to fully
understanding how the I.T infrastructure
for the state is handled
but um you know I'm sure the the
department has expertise and it's
actually first I want to say welcome uh
uh The Honorable Sean Chester he was my
representative one of my representatives
for many years but uh
um
the
you know I would not expect the
Department of Agriculture to have
much expertise in managing software
projects and just having one it employee
is not
doesn't help a lot in that regard so my
question is
the impression I get from the fiscal
note is that that and from what you says
the Department's actually managing this
project is that true and if so why isn't
I don't know if it's doit I mean we had
the CIO in here earlier for another bill
why aren't they involved in managing the
project I would have expected that the
Department of Agriculture would just
provide expertise on the process and
somebody else would actually implement
this
thank you for the question and my
apologies for not being clear Joe
Bentley who is behind here and will be
testifying works for dlit he is now in
the department full-time so he resides
there so he is doing all this work he
put the numbers together he has been
going around spending time with all the
division heads
finding out what their needs are and
then developing everything to do it so
they finally are doing that for us that
only came across because it came to be
because of the scope of the animal
database which was approved some time
ago and
um is now finally out out to bid but yes
they are doing that because we have no
expertise and you know it's
it's a like a a new world for us
all right thank you okay
thank you madam chair um and thank you
for taking my uh question commissioner
uh
what I'm hearing
I I don't by the way I don't claim to be
anywhere near an expert on agriculture
but what I'm hearing is an emergency
call for action
I could describe your your testimony
back to me that's what I'm hearing
particular yes thank you thank you for
the question that is particularly true
in in weights and measures and if that
system crashes we don't know what we're
going to do it's been band-aided
together this is part of it
but if there is a crash between now and
then we might have to do something
something else but you know we do
000 pesticides registrations a year
entering stuff in we do
000 feed products entered in by hand so
there's you know just all over the place
there's all the people who who come in
who are
um licensed
to uh to apply pesticides licensed as
you know plant dealers and and we're
just way behind the time it's just you
know follow-up
uh thank you madam chair so so I'm
hearing that emergency call for action
however as you know especially in your
background uh the the way we do things
is often through collaborative support
for each other especially when issues
and emergencies
present themselves and uh what
representative Bixby brought us is a is
a bill that has zero co-sponsors either
in the senate or in the house and I feel
bad for him because I feel like he's
been left out to dry a little bit on
this
and so we've got to rely on that and I'd
like to be able to look at co-sponsors
and and see them all knowing their head
up and down this is we really got to
lean out and do this to help out the
department uh I don't see that so can
you explain what happened the fact that
we we don't have uh this collaborative
force of co-sponsors
um well sometimes that happens some
sometimes it doesn't often in the case
of a request from an agency
there isn't that that Outreach that
really
had
representative Bixby
felt the need I probably could have
reached out to to some people generally
the sponsors reach out to others but
this sort of came together at the last
at the last minute I think and and I
would ask you not to look at the the
lack of co-sponsors as indicative of of
the need or the crisis I mean we don't
work on a general basis that closely
with a lot of of legislators
um last session uh it was really rep now
Senator Pearl who we worked with he was
on a number of our bills this year who I
reached out to
um and representative Bixby those have
been our two go-to people in the in the
house we really didn't have a go-to
person in the Senate before so most of
our bills were really uh developed in in
the house and I can't speak to how many
co-sponsors were on on there but we have
a relatively small pool of of people who
we we go to who understand the issues
and uh and have helped us greatly thank
you madam chair
representative O'Brien
thank you madam chair and
uh commission it's good to see you again
good to see you um
just seems so much like a bread and
butter issue and I understand working
for uh
municipality and the benefits of
Band-Aids but why did you not put it
into the budget you know trying to get
in and I think some it was a question
asked before you came in the room and
I'll give you the opportunity to clear
that up
yes
um because we are given parameters by
the governor
and
our budget requests also started
um back in September
and Joe when did you come on board
he came on in June and was getting his
feet wet and the the first thing was to
worry about the animal database and
learning about that
my understanding from talking to others
I haven't heard this directly from the
governor's
staff at this time they may actually be
considering putting this in the in the
budget personally I'm a little bit
afraid of that I've been around for too
many budget processes to know that bills
become law very often long before
budgets become law
and I feel a lot safer actually having
this as an independent Bill rather than
getting tied up with the possibility of
a budget which you know may go to a
continuing resolution may go on until
the Lord only knows when I'd rather have
something that takes effect July 1st for
sure
follow-up how distrustful of you
commissioner
just experience
so commissioner then in Reading between
the lines of what you said Fair answer
uh the support of this committee would
probably assist
uh the governor and to uh making a wise
choice I would I would hope so I would
certainly you know ask and hope that
this this committee realizes that we
have sort of been the uh the stepchild
of departments uh when it comes to RIT
needs for decades
um and that's nobody's fault outside of
the department but within the department
nobody to blame because you don't know
what you don't know and I think a lot of
us assumed in erroneously so that doit
would see what our needs were and would
put us in the queue for things and since
I've become more educated on things
things I realized that's not how it it
happens it's sort of like being your
your own Advocate with your doctor
that's what you have to be and
unfortunately we were not very good at
advocates for our needs
any other questions representative thank
you um just a clarification there was a
implication that
this system would would among other
things replace the weights and measures
one is that correct it it is the numbers
have been developed that way yes
um that it is included it is included in
here it looks like there's you know it's
a fairly expensive part the rest of what
is out there may be more off the shelf
um Mr Bentley can speak better to to
those issues than I can he developed the
numbers understanding the needs and
believe me I am no I T person a quick
follow-up follow-up yeah it just uh my
concern was whether this bill and this
um the cost here did include weights and
measures and I'm glad to hear that it
does thank you okay any other questions
representative Schmidt
thank you ma'am chair
good afternoon commissioner
um
so if I understand correctly uh this is
an early bill
yes okay so our call here is to make the
policy decision the financial side will
be just determined if it passes the
house on our recommendation as to policy
that the finance committee will have a
go at it to consider and determine the
financial end of things and to some
degree maybe in Ways and Means because
it certainly will be Revenue raising in
in some fashion so
um
if I if I recall correctly when I served
on environment and agriculture committee
17 years ago
agriculture in those days represented
about one-fifth of the New Hampshire
economy would you say that it is likely
comparable in this day and age
I really don't want to comment on that
because I I honestly don't know when you
take all of Agriculture as as a whole
it's it's a large sector
um but I didn't come here with with any
of those numbers prepared and I'm not
sure that there are any that are up to
date at the moment but it certainly does
have a large well what my follow-up
question if I may Madam chair would be
uh in in any case it's a significant
part of the New Hampshire economy and
it's not functioning as well they your
department is not functioning as well as
it could if it were in the 2000s instead
of in the 1980s
and therefore would it not be uh your
request that the policy committee weigh
in in favor of this bill you're here in
support I take it I am in a hundred
percent agreement with your statements
representative Smith thank you very much
I couldn't have stated that better
representative goalie
thank you madam chair
just a quick question for the chair
well I look at this bill and it deals
with electronic licensing certification
and registration I don't believe it's
the licensing registration and
certification that this committee
generally deals with correct that's
correct if I had looked at this more
closely we might have tried to uh vacate
it directly to finance because
I mean from a policy point of view it's
not necessarily our well I don't know we
do license weights and measures
inspectors
um which is apparently the largest part
of this this project but that's a
thank you
yeah no it's
so yeah and really representative Gould
thank you madam chair just a quick one
and thank you commissioner for taking my
question so when we talk about the
portion of the economy that's
um Farm labor and I understand you can't
give numbers then we talk about weights
and measures weights and measures also
covers like firewood and lumber is that
correct yes and and thank you you make
make an excellent point because this is
more than agriculture because when you
look at
um pesticides
most I shouldn't say most but thousands
and thousands of homeowners are involved
in that by hiring companies to come in
treat their lawns take care of insects
that's outside of the traditional
Agriculture and we service all those
people and license all of those products
same is true of weights and measures
um
virtually every single thing that is
sold by a weight or measure from
firewood to the beer in your
refrigerator we have oversight on I I
thought you'd like that representative
O'Brien so you know those are the those
are the things that we have over
oversight on we've been dealing with a
candy company who was not
taking off the weight of the lollipop
step sticks in wrappers known as tear
so even your lollipops you know we're
dealing with that and protecting you
from having to pay for those paper
wrappers and weights and measures
anything like that it's always amazing
to people when they find out what we
actually are in in charge of overseeing
um just what a large footprint we have
in the state of New Hampshire you
virtually you know of course the gas
pumps there is virtually nothing that
you probably do in a week
or you probably can't go a week without
um buying something that we are uh that
we're not in charge of because
food in the grocery store by volume all
of those things so we have a very large
footprint
[Music]
all right yeah I'd like to mention to
the committee that as representative
goalie pointed out this is not our usual
type of
licensing but I mean and the cost
basically they're covering it from the
the existing fees so
we shouldn't worry too much whether it's
a hundred thousand or three hundred
thousand or half a million because you
you have enough to cover it
none okay uh Mr Bentley please
hello
good morning good afternoon please
introduce yourself and uh yes I'm sorry
if this is my first time here I'm new
with the state
um my name is Joe Bentley I work for
Department of Information Technology and
I actually sit with agriculture so I
spent the last seven months learning as
much as I can about them and
whatnot
I just realized as well that my hearing
is not so good so apologize for that
okay
all right yes
he really is here more
questions okay
all right thank you are there any
questions
I think we wore ourselves out on the
commissioner so you're uh you're off the
hook
you're seeing none I thank you very much
thank you for your time
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill 230.
seeing nominal close the public hearing
all right
all right if we were to go into
executive session would anyone have a
motion
representative Gould
okay
I've never made a motion Madam chair
this will be my first so forgive me if
my form is improper but I'd like to move
this bill as ought to pass but thank you
that's exactly the right uh right format
is there a second second representative
O'Brien second it's okay
those goalie oh excuse me I'm
um
Gentlemen please
it'll be fire hoses at 30 Paces
otherwise
representative Gould would you like to
speak to your motion
uh yes thank you madam chair as an
organic farmer and and coming from
Warner where we have in water and
Bradford in our district there are a lot
of organic farmers young farmers who are
working really hard and being the wife
of a logger
I really appreciate the need for us to
pay attention to what the Department of
Agriculture needs and
um I feel that the organic farmers
waiting for certification for or for
organic status those kind of matters are
much more important the data entry so
I'm really happy to see this bill and
happy to move for ought to pass
thank you represent goalie
thank you madam chair after listening to
the testimony and hearing about the
Antiquated system that they have over
there and the dire need for an upgrade
I think this is uh money well spent and
seeing that it will be at no cost and
it's going to be used used by um
money that the department is already
generating I think this is a wise
investment all right does anyone else
have a comment question
representative Lucas I guess my only
editorial one is I don't consider it no
cost I mean the money's coming in it's
going in the general fund so it can be
used for something and if it's spent on
this it can't be spent on something else
but I I will be voting for this you're
totally correct
okay any other representative Dolan
thank you madam chair I I still I'm a
little concerned that an expenditure of
this amount is not in the budget and has
not been vetted by any of our colleagues
in terms of co-sponsoring well this is
an early Bill and it is going to finance
and I can assure you they will vet every
dollar
in the cost of the software
thank you
representative Schmidt yeah thank you
madam chair
yes representative Dolan as I pointed
out
we are the policy committee not the
finance committee our charge is whether
this is a wise step for the state to
take that the money is not our business
that's what the finance committee will
decide if and when the bill passes the
house so I invite in case you have not
been over there go across the street and
walk into the Department of Agriculture
welcome to the 1800s okay they are
behind the times with regard to
technology and and and when I was on the
finance commit sorry the agriculture
committee 17 years ago I had the
opportunity to tour a number of farms
specialty farms and so forth agriculture
is is holding its own in the state of
New Hampshire we're not growing corn
that's for Iowa and Illinois in the
midwest but we are producing a lot of
specialty goods and I I don't think that
the
percentage of the economy of the State
of New Hampshire that was represented 17
years ago which was about a fifth of the
economy has declined substantially and
it could be doing a lot better if the
department could get out of the 1800s so
I will be enthusiastically supporting
this Bill yes and representative Dolan
it's not exactly true that money is is
not our concern work
Our concern should be that the money is
reasonable for the type of thing that
we're doing we don't need to worry
whether it's three hundred thousand or
four hundred thousand we need to say
it's significantly less than the amount
of fees they bring in and it requires no
additional staff
and then we'll let the finance committee
sweat the details of how of whether the
you know the what the price is
but you know the previous Bill we looked
at the at the cost and said
that is a massive amount of Manpower
that we don't want to ask the state to
spend
it
whereas in this case it's it's not so
that that's the difference
any other comments representative shuitt
yes there you are thank you madam chair
um I will be voting for this
um particularly with an appreciation for
the commissioner's comments about fears
of putting something like this in the
budget
those of us have been around a while
know that anything that goes in the
budget is subject to the whims of a
committee of conference
and sometimes very important things get
cut out when deals are cut when the
final budget is is established by that
Committee of conference so I can
appreciate what the commissioner was
saying and hoping that this can go
through as a standalone Bill thank you
okay
any other comments questions concerns
okay seeing none the motion is ought to
pass by representative Gould and the
clerk can call the roll
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey yes
representative San Antonio yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative Aber yes
representative Gerhard
yes
the clerk votes yes
representative grotta yes representative
Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
schuette yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
and the chair yes
18 yay zero name
okay
thank you very much the motion passes
18-0 are there any objections to consent
okay seeing none we will put it on
consent and thank you
ah yes you're right you can't go on
consent because of the fiscal note
thank you for reminding me of that
okay
all right uh thank you all for coming we
will resume 10 o'clock tomorrow with our
uh
after completing software day
foreign